ceramic grills use natural lump charcoal
which is made by taking hardwoods like
oak and hickory and carbonizing them
through a heating process cooking with
this type of charcoal is just like
cooking over a campfire at this factory
they begin by making a slurry a mixture
of raw materials that harden into
ceramic material when fired at high
temperature the company won't divulge
the exact composition of its slurry
other than to say that the main
ingredients are water clay and feldspar
another team assembles the two-part
plaster mold with which they'll cast at
the base of the grille after cleaning
off residue from the previous casting
they clamp the parts together the mold
has two funnels one through which they
pump the watery slurry into the mold and
the other for the air which exits as the
slurry fills the gap between the two
parts of the mold
they let the slurry set for several
hours to allow the plaster mold to
absorb 80% of the water leaving a firm
but still moist casting after removing
the top part of the mold they slice off
the accumulation at the base of both
funnels they cut out a rectangular hole
near the bottom for the sliding draught
door which lets cold air into the grille
then using a vacuum attached to a hoist
they remove the heavy grille base from
the mold they repeat this casting
process with two part molds for the
other ceramic parts of the grille the
top called the dome and the firebox
which sits inside the base and holds the
charcoal after each casting they scrape
and sand away the excess that oozed out
of the mold and hardened to remove the
remaining moisture they roll the cast
parts into a dryer for the next 30 hours
blowers circulate air gradually heated
to 82 degrees Celsius after a cool-down
the base and dome undergo a final
touch-up to ensure their exterior
surface is pristine next stop the
automated glazing station the conveyor
spins the parts under a shower of
ceramic glaze a worker checks the
coverage and sprays a touch-up where
required
the glaze dries in about 20 seconds
workers vacuum up the excess
then temporarily assemble the grill
parts for firing they place the firebox
inside the base the base plate at the
bottom of the firebox and the dome on
top of the base they fire the grills in
a huge kill over 24 hours they gradually
increase the temperature to more than
1300 degrees Celsius hold it there for a
set time then gradually cool down this
firing process triggers a chemical
reaction that transforms the clay-based
slurry into a hard heat-resistant
ceramic material and turns the glaze on
the surface into black glass assembly of
the grille begins with the stainless
steel draft door on the base next they
spread adhesive on the top edge of the
base and apply a gasket made of
heat-resistant material this creates an
air seal between the base and the dome
which they now attach with a hinge they
insert the firebox
and stamp it then they glue a gasket
around the neck of the dome and install
the top fit now the last few components
the cast iron grate that holds the
charcoal the porcelain coated cooking
grates and the thermometer after
lighting the charcoal you adjust the air
flow with the draft door and top vent to
shut down the grill you fully close the
draft door and top vent to cut off the
air supply and extinguish the fire